hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well something like a
state or an action that epictetus thinks
is very important for people to
cultivate and to deploy if they're going
to make any consistent progress in
stoicism and therefore towards happiness
it is what we can call a tenth attention
or attentiveness or mindfulness the
Greek for that is prose focus and it
does actually have quite a wide range of
meaning that you see when we look at at
chapter 12 which is devoted specifically
to this topic this is a term that's
going to show up running throughout the
discourses another term that sometimes
gets translated as attention or
attentiveness is having the lace you
know but I think they're fairly
synonymous so the it doesn't make sense
to translate them both the same way and
what you know why is attention so
important well it's important to
maintain or pay attention in activities
Epictetus will say why because if we
want to do them well we actually have to
do
attentively or if you like the
parliament's that people are using these
days of mindfulness and you think about
eating mindfully and practicing the
violin mindfully and dressing yourself
mindfully that's that's fine too the
idea is that you're you're focusing in
some way on what it is that you're doing
you're not allowing your attention
you're not allowing your mind to slip
off into other things and then to start
doing things automatically on its own
you want to be there you want to be
present you want to be in control so he
says you know what what is to prevent
your playing if you want to play but
with the tension what is to prevent your
singing but with attention there's no
part of the activities of your life to
which attention does not extend if you
decide for that to be the case so it's
possible for us to be attentive a lot of
the time you know towards the end of
this this section actually he feels a
question where somebody says can we
never be totally perfect you know paying
attention that everything is probably
not where we're usually going to screw
up at one point or another but then it
doesn't mean that we can't have a
greater as opposed to a less so he says
you know when we think about the the
carpenter does the inattentive carpenter
do his work more accurately or it is the
helmsman the pilot of a boat does the
inattentive helmsman steer more safely
are there any of the other lesser
functions of life which have done better
by an attention than the answer clearly
is no when people are paying attention
to what they're doing they're going to
do a better job with it so if we
understand the human being in a broader
sense as having a function that runs
throughout their entire life as
epictetus and the Stoics do then it
makes sense that we would want to pay
attention more generally so that we can
fulfill the purposes of a human being
better and so we can keep ourselves on
that we intend to or at least say that
we attempt to so he says do that let do
you not realize when you let your mind
go wandering it's no longer than within
your power to recall it to bring it to
bear either upon seemly Ness or some
respect or moderation but you do
anything that comes into your head you
follow your inclinations then this is
often what does in fact happen to us we
find ourselves losing track and what's
going on you know here's a great example
when you go to academic conferences
academic conferences are not
particularly
what'll designed for for the purposes
that they're supposed to serve which is
you know facilitating the exchange of
information research and then you know
criticizing that or playing off of that
making contacts all that sort of stuff
because you go to these sessions and if
it's you know there are breaks in
between the sessions that's great but
sometimes the breaks are so short it's
just enough time to go out and get
yourself some coffee you know shake a
few hands get back sit in your seat and
now you're drinking your coffee trying
to stay awake and the speaker gets up
and they're the first of three speakers
and they start talking about something
and you don't have their paper in front
of you
and you're listening for a while and
following what they're saying and now
your mind starts wandering and you start
thinking about I wonder what it would be
a good place to go for lunch
I wonder if so-and-so is here at the
conference and now you you suddenly come
back and you're like crap what did I
miss
and you can't follow the paper at all or
you're there and you're kind of tired
and keeping your eyes open up again that
just doesn't work right there's all
sorts of things like this where
somebody's having a conversation with
you and I really pay attention because
you're thinking about something else or
you're on your phone phones are terrible
for this good thing or you're looking
out the window because you'd really
rather not be there there's all sorts of
ways in which lack of attention coat can
go wrong thinking about driving as a
great example how many times
have you wound up somewhere and then you
realize that you really were not paying
close attention in any conscious way to
your drive while you were doing it
you're like whoa that last hour went
very quickly there's a lot of ways in
which lack of attention our mindfulness
can be a serious problem for us not only
in in respect of individual actions but
thinking about our broader life where we
want to go what it is that we want to do
so he talks about the relationship
between attentiveness and actions and
habits and he brings up two particularly
bad habits which are created by giving
it by not exerting attention attention
is itself something that we have to
develop a habit ah
so if we don't do that we can develop a
bad habit of either not paying attention
not paying attention at all some people
have a very difficult time focusing or
they need certain material props like I
know people for example who cannot study
unless they have the TV and you know
quite frankly they're not really
studying help with the TV on because
they're half listening to what's going
on on the TV
some people are that way with the radio
particularly particularly if they grew
up in a noisy household where solitude
and study was not something that had a
premium it's easy to follow to a habit
of not paying attention and it's easy to
fall into the habit of deferring or
putting off in time devoting attention
to things this notion that yeah I never
really need to pay attention right now
because I will pay attention when I go
back to the book I can just sort of skim
through it at this moment and I'll focus
later on and then later on does it come
or doesn't it come if you remind
yourself hey you were going to actually
read the book and read it seriously
two days ago time to get to it you know
you could say the same thing with any
other
thing that we might pay attention to our
conversation partners you know spouses
friends people on bus students
this isn't anybody with room we share
this this relationship of conversation
when we think about things that we
actually do for our self-improvement
am I going to exercise and lift weights
great so I'll get some dumbbells and
start doing curls but do I just do them
whatever weight I want to or should I
actually pay attention to what I'm doing
so I'm doing the exercise properly so
I'll derive benefit I said well I'm
gonna do it my way today and then next
time when I get here all I'll pay
attention to but what happens is when we
do that we develop these bad habits and
these habits like we've seen there's an
entire video that I've done just done
epic - you see they become part of the
fabric of our Faculty of choice and we
easily slide back into them so it
becomes difficult through our own you
know efforts or lack of effort for us to
exert an effort later on he says you
grow accustomed to putting on from from
one time to another tranquil and
appropriate living the life in
accordance with nature and persistence
in that life that's that putting off
attention you know chapter four point
three kappa 3 sorry book 4 he has
another discussion the tension and he
says little is needed to ruin an upset
everything
only a slight aberration from reason for
the helmsman to upset his ship he does
not need the same amount of preparation
as he does to keep it safe but if he
heads a little bit too much into the
wind he's lost yes even if he does
nothing by his own deliberate choice but
merely falls to thinking about something
else for a moment he's lost in life that
patina says it's very much the same if
you dose for about a moment all that
you've amassed
- is gone exaggerating a little bit
there but he says pay attention
therefore to your appearances and watch
over them sleeplessly for it's no small
matter that your garden it's it's your
entire prior racist right so he says you
have to pay attention you have to devote
mindfulness to that we we have it's a so
it's easy to slide it back into a lack
of progress by not paying attention and
we shouldn't think at any given moment
that we lose our attention that it's
just about that moment because of this
dysfunction of habits so what should we
pay attention to he tells us you know
four main things the first are by far
the most important since first those
general principles was Catholic will be
Catholic like the word that we actually
get Catholic from general right Cavazos
that and in the way of the the you know
the the general of the whole we should
have these as he says ready yet him Pro
Skater try ever his hand in in Greek so
Pro Skater would mean ready at hand we
need to think about these general
principles what are that he gives us
some examples that no man is a master of
another's moral purpose and in the moral
purpose or the Faculty of choice
although boner to be found ones good and
evil nobody can procure me good or
involve me with evil but I myself have
authority over myself in these matters
these are examples what in other places
he calls dog Mata you know the beliefs
or the judgments that we want to have in
mind now what does it mean to have them
in hand and to be paying attention to
them does it mean that at every given
moment I've got to be thinking about
them all the time consciously no to have
them ready at him means that I do think
about them certainly at least several
times a day and then when I run into a
situation that calls for that I find
myself for example getting upset with
somebody because I think they're harming
me and then I remind myself right
I do that by being mindful I remind
myself and say you know that guy can't
really harm me only my judgement about
him harming me can really harm me and
that's up to me so if we keep those
general principles in mind we will keep
ourselves on the right track that's
really important that's that's
absolutely essential for epictetus also
very important are our roles and our
duties as he said remembering who we
actually are here we go who we are and
what is our name our designation and we
must endeavor to direct our actions and
the performance of our duties to meet
the possibilities of our social
relations we are situated beings I am a
son I am a spouse I am a father right I
am duties that are coming upon me
neighbor teacher fellow citizen all of
these impose certain duties upon myself
and it's very easy to lose sight of them
and to develop the habit of not paying
attention to that or put it off the
attention yeah I'll worry about what it
means to be a good spouse later on
because because right now I got other
stuff I got a handle right I have to get
myself right first now that I can worry
about my other people involved in my
life Epictetus would say don't delay too
long because you're gonna find yourself
delaying forever if you do that because
it's going to become oh yeah the proper
times and occasions for activities it
isn't the right time for playing music
you know he talks about singing for
example what's the proper time for play
another one the luck people get very
mixed up about when when should we be
you know joking around and when should
we be serious when should we relax and
when should we focus on our
attentiveness on the work that we need
to get done people get very mixed up
about this in part because they
let these things slide finally he says
how to maintain one's proper character
in social situations social situations
like I talked about in another video on
Epictetus they present us with some real
challenges we can get sort of sucked in
and forget who and what we are because
of what's going on around us and that's
our own fault view says when that
happens we can't say well the devil made
me do it
or so-and-so made me do the peer
pressure made me do it it's our own lack
of attentiveness our own staying focused
that ends up being one of the the key
problems in that case so very important
to cultivate a habit attention or or
mindfulness from a static perspective